لن تسافر اليوم ستؤجل رحلتها وكذا رحلاتهم
وقد تلغى وذاك شان اغلب الرحلات الجويه
المنطلقه من مطار بن جوريون في تل ابيب
وفي الاتجاه الاخر لا تزال شركات الطيران
العالميه تواصل الغاء رحلاتها باتجاه
اسرائيل كفى بذلك كله دافعا الى حاله
الاستياء
المستشرين
حاله سريعا ما تستبدل باخرى ملؤها الرعب
والهلع اثر سقوط قذائف صاروخيه اطلقتها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه على مناطق قريبه من
المطار اضطراب حركه السفر جوا هو احد
افرازات حاله الحرب التي دخلها
الاسرائيليون رسميا بقرار من
حكومتهم اتبعت قياده الجبه الداخليه
القراره بما لم يحدث منذ عقود امرت سكان
30 مستوطن
بمناطق الشمال بالنزول الى الملاجئ على
الفور تحسبا من اي طارئ هذا وضع بدا جديدا
على اسرائيل التي اربك طوفان الاقصى كما
يبدو مختلف مناحي الحياه
فيها بل سرعان ما اصابها
بالشلل قطاع السياحه والسفر تلقى ضربه
موجعه الغيت حجوزات الفنادق وغادر السياح
ممن امكنهم
السفر من تداعيات حاله الحرب الاخرى ان
اغلقت الشركات والمحال التجاريه ابوابها
وعلقت الدراسه في جميع المؤسسات
التعليميه لكن في الجانب الاقتصادي الصرف
بدت ملامح المرحله اكثر
وضوحا علق عملاق النفط والغاز الامريكي
شيفرون انشطته في منصه تمار لاستخراج
الغاز وذلك التزاما بما قالت الشركه انها
تعليمات الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على صعيد سوق المال سجلت
بورصه تل ابيب انخفاضا حادا في اسهم كبرى
الشركات الاسرائيليه والمؤشرات
الرئيسيه وفقدت الاسهم الاسرائيليه اكثر
من 16 مليار دولار من قيمتها السوقيه وذلك
بعد ان تكبد مؤشر البورصه اكبر خساره
يوميه له منذ جائحه كورونا لكن ماذا عن
الشيكل هبطت العمله الاسرائيليه الى ادنى
مستوى ها منذ ثمان سنوات امام الدولار
الامريكي يعد البنك المركزي الاسرائيلي
بالتدخل في سوق النقد لتخفيف التقلبات في
سعر صرف الشيكل وتوفير سيوله لاستمرار عمل
الاسواق
بكفاءه غير ان المزيد من ضعف الشيكل
وتراجعه امام الدولار والعملات الاجنبيه
قد يؤدي الى ارتفاع اسعار المنتجات
المستورده في الايام المقبله معنى ذلك
ازدياد حاجه بنك اسرائيل الى رفع اسعار
الفائده